Transcriber: Carol Matouk
المدقّق: rana heloun
قبل سنتين، وفي بطولة ودية للشطرنج
والتي كانت أول بطولة أشارك فيها
كهاوٍ للشطرنج بعمر الخمسة عشر.
لم أكن أتوقع الكثير من هذه البطولة.
بعد خبرتي التي لم تكن تتجاوز
الخمسة أشهر في تعلم الشطرنج.
ضد مجموعة من أفضل لاعبي الشطرنج في سوريا.
المباراة الأولى انتهت بتعادل
مع لاعب هاوٍ مثلي.
ولكن في المباراة الثانية
تم تقريني مع أحد اللاعبين المحترفين.
لاعب قدّم ما لا يقل
عن ثمان سنواتٍ في تعلّم الشطرنج.
قبل بداية المبارة كنت مقتنع بحتيمة الخسارة
ولكنني على الرغم من ذلك لعبت.
ومع تقدم المباراة التي استمرت
لأكثر من أربعين دقيقة.
ما كان للاعبٍ أفضلية على الآخر.
ولكن فجأة.. الآن ستكون المفاجأة..
اقترف خصمي خطأ وأكسبني أفضلية مُطلقة.
وكنت قد بدأت أربح.
لم أكن مقتنعاً أنني قادرٌ
على التغلب على هذا الشخص.
لهذا أمضيتُ خمساً من التسع دقائق
المتبقية من وقتي في التفكير
بالمكيدة خلف هذه الحركة.
حركة بعد حركة يبدأ وقتي بالنفاذ
وأخسر تلك المباراة.
ليس بسبب عدم قدرتي على الفوز
في ذلك الموقف المحدد.
ولكن لأنني توترت واقترفت هذا الخطأ الساذج.
وكان توقعي مختلف لمسار المباراة.
من منكم مرّ بموقفٍ مشابه؟
مواقف جديدة لم نكن نتوقعها
ولم نكن قد خططنا لها.
منذ أن نكون طلاباً في المدرسة
وبعد اكتمال خطتنا الدراسية
إلى أن حين تخططينا لانجاز عمل ما
وعدم التزامنا بالخطة بحذافيرها
دائماً ما تسيطر علينا حينها
مشاعر التوتر والقلق.
وتقلّ عزيمتنا للعمل أو تنعدم.
فقط لأننا لم نلتزم بهذه الخطة بحذافيرها.
هذا غير أثرها المدمر على صحتنا النفسية.
من ممارسات تلقائية ترافق هذا الفشل.
مثل الإحساس بعدم الأهمية وجلد الذات.
ولكن في المقابل،
في حياتنا اليومية
معظم أعمالنا تكون بلا تخطيط
ولا نواجه أية مشاكل بالتكيُف.
فقط لأن هذا التوتر لم يتدخل
حتى يدمر القدرة على الابتكار والتكيُف.
ونجاح الخطة غير الثابتة
لا يقتصر على المواقف اليومية البسيطة.
إن عدنا قليلاً بالتاريخ،
سنجد مواقفاً مشابهة ولكنها أدت إلى نجاح.
مثل أول محاولة إقلاع طائرة بمحرك ميكانيكي
والتي انتهت بالفشل في أول محاولة.
ولكن..
أو في أول محاولة أو خطة..
لكن ثاني محاولة والتي
كانت باليوم نفسه تكللت بالنجاح.
والقصص كثيرة عن فشل تنفيذ الخطة
المبدئية ولكن الوصول للنجاح كنتيجة.
هناك مدرسة فكرية تأسست في اليونان
القديمة تحت اسم الرواقية.
برسالة أساسية وهي بما معناه
أننا لا نتحكم بما يحصل معنا
ولكننا نتحكم بكيفية ردة فعلنا عليه.
هذا كان تلخيص لسبب اختلاف النتيجة
بيني وبين الذي وصل للنجاح.
رغم أن خطتنا المبدئية نحن الاثنان لم تنجح.
أنا كان هدفي هو لعب المباراة وفق يقينٍ
واحد وهو إني أكيد راح أخسر .
والثاني كان هدفه أن يجعل الطائرات
تقلع بغض النظر عن الطريقة.
أجل، الفرق بيننا كان سببه
أنني لم أتمكن من التحكم بردة فعلي
تجاه هذا الموقف.
وهناك الكثير من القصص عن أشخاصٍ
لم تنجح بخطتها المبدئية.
الآن.
حسناً، ما الذي يمكن أن يتغيّر
في المرات القادمة؟
ما يمكننا تغييره في المرات القادمة
هو بالتأكيد ليس عدم التخطيط.
من المعروف أن أساس الإبداع هو عدم التخطيط.
ولكن التخطيط مهم جداً كما نعلم جميعنا.
ما يمكننا تغييره في المرات القادمة
هو أن نضع خططاً مناسبة لنا.
مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار،
أن قدرتنا على العمل تختلف بين يومٍ وآخر.
وأيضاً أن نضع خطة مرنة قابلة للتعديل
مع المتغيرات التي يمكن أن تحصل
خلال فترة تنفيذ المشروع.
هذه هي الخطة المرنة.
مع ترك مجال للأحداث الطارئة
على الجدول الزمني لتنفيذ المشروع.
لولا أن تخليت عن إيماني المطلق
المتراكم من سبع عشرة سنة
أنني لن أتمكن من أكون متحدثاً
أمام هذا العدد الكبير من الناس.
لما كنت متواجداً على منصة (تيد) اليوم
في خطابٍ كنت قد خططت أن يكون سبع دقائق.
ولكن كما ترون،
شكرأ.